manifestation non autorisée s'est
regroupée à la sortie du métro invalides
à 16 heures près du ministère des
affaires étrangères elle est consécutive
aux frappes de l'armée israélienne sur
la bande de gaza qui a fait quelques
dizaines de morts dont des enfants
cette situation indigne les militants de
la cause palestinienne ils sont ils
étaient une centaine environ avec des
élus du parti communiste d'europe
écologie les verts ou encore des
insoumis on les écoute ce qui se passe
sur place
c'est qu'une nouvelle fois une guerre a
démarré qui va être disproportionnée
contre qui a démarré contre le peuple à
gaza où déjà une quarantaine de
personnes sont mortes une dizaine
d'enfants
alors bien sûr disons le immédiatement
les tirs de roquettes du hamas nous les
dénonçons ils sont inacceptables mais la
réponse du gouvernement israélien est
totalement disproportionnée et nous
appelons la communauté internationale et
en premier lieu le gouvernement français
à réagir on ne peut pas se contenter
simplement de rappeler le droit
international et de renvoyer dos à dos
les acteurs ce n'est pas possible je
peux vous dire que depuis quelques jours
la mobilisation est extrêmement forte
vis-à-vis du gouvernement français il ya
eu des questions parlementaires en
séance à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat
il y a des dizaines de députés de toutes
de tous les partis qui sont en train de
faire partir une lettre au président de
la république pour leur dire que ce
n'est pas possible et qu'il faut que
cela cesse et que la position de la
france doit changer
donc oui la mobilisation est forte et où
nous sommes déterminés d'abord marquer
notre solidarité avec le peuple
palestinien mais aussi à le faire de
manière à ce que la position du
gouvernement français évoluent assez de
c'est aussi notre on est là aussi pour
cent après les drapeaux agités les
slogans la police avait verbalisé
quelques militants pour les dissuader de
rester et a évacué les autres pour
évoquer cette situation préoccupante et
le risque d' escalade une délégation
d'associations pour la palestine a été
reçue par le quai d'orsay à 17 heures